quel message on envoie au 50 000 jeunes
qui l'ont fait on leur dit qu'ils ont
été inutiles parce qu'ils ont fait le
SNU c'est c'est insupportable à entendre
et quel message on envoie au 64000
jeunes qui sont inscrits pour le faire
cette année écoutez ces jeunes allez les
voir plutôt que de dire des journaux
vous verrez qu'ils sont enthousiastes
qui sentent une reconnaissance qui se
sentent inutile et qu'ils ont appris des
choses en complément du projet de
l'éducation nationale
[Musique]
service national universel ne nous
semble pas dans les différentes formes
proposées ces derniers mois être à même
de remplir le rôle qui lui est promis il
fait l'objet de nombreux débats et
notamment de rejets nombreux enseignants
et de nombreux jeunes notamment des
syndicats lycéens mais aussi de très
mauvais échos dans son cadrement la
dernière mouture dévoilée dans politique
ne répond même plus à l'enjeu de mixité
sociale qui avait pourtant été mis en
avant dans un premier temps un signe
universel ni valorisation de
l'engagement ce dispositif ne rapproche
pas l'armée et la défense nationale de
notre jeunesse mais fait-on entrer une
symbolique simplificatrice dans le de la
discipline militaire dans l'éducation
nationale des valorisant de ce fait nos
armées et l'éducation nationale
aujourd'hui le service national
universel est sur la base du volontariat
évidemment du fait du nombre
d'amendements et du débat que ça porte
il y aura un moment un débat
parlementaire permettant de savoir si le
fnu a vocation va devenir obligatoire ou
de rester sur la base du volontariat ce
débat vous arrivera le service national
universel profondément apporte quelque
chose à notre jeunesse profondément lui
permet d'avoir des outils nouveaux sur
les questions de mixité et sociales et
territoriales venez voir venez
participer à ces séjours
des encadrants et je suis j'ai la
certitude mais l'intime conviction que
le regard sur ce dispositif évoluera
l'expérience que j'ai du SNU c'est une
fierté retrouvée pour ceux qui
participent j'étais à l'arc triomphe
avec des jeunes du SNU qui venaient de
banlieue en uniforme et qui rendait
hommage aux soldats inconnus c'est la
belle jeunesse de France
j'ai vu
des jeunes venant de toutes les origines
dans le SNU dans mon département de
Seine-et-Marne et qui grâce à cela
connaissait une mixité qu'il n'aurait
jamais connu autrement